der gigantische ice cube detektor im
südpolarmeer bricht immer neue rekorde
jetzt hat ja das erste antineutrinos aus
dem universum entdeckt dass ein 60 jahre
altes rätsel der physik endlich lösen
könnte und ein gigantisch geladenes
neutrino aus einer gezeiten katastrophe
und der detektor soll noch gigantischer
werden tipps und news gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen am schluss
dieses videos habe ich noch eine
ziemlich coole zoom konferenz für euch
das thema das space race 2.0
der wettlauf ins weltall und ihr könnt
dabei sein und hier auf tricks um
exklusiv unter anderem mit esa
generaldirektor josef aschbacher und der
astronautin kandidatin in satire ein
zusammentreffen anmelden könnt euch hier
untergeht der link ist natürlich auch in
der video beschreibung und im
angehefteten kommentar der ice cube
detektor in der arktis der ist wirklich
ein gigantisches observatorium ice cube
das zu amerikanischen armut und scott
forschungsstation am südpol gehört ist
wohl eines der spannendsten experimente
weltweit 5160 sensoren wurden dafür tief
in den antarktischen untergrund versenkt
und zwar bis zu zweieinhalb kilometer
tief zusammen bieten sie ein riesiges
dreidimensionales detektor fällt seine
größe einmal einmal ein kilometer 1
kopie kilometer das ist schon der
absolute wahnsinn
hier soll die sogenannte cherenkov
strahlung erforscht werden damit es das
leuchten gemeint dass durch die
kollision von neutrinos mit den
wassermolekülen des eis entsteht und das
passiert nicht oft schätzungsweise ein
paar tausend mal im jahr
doch wenn es passiert dann richtig pro
sekunde prallen nämlich zwischen 60 und
100 milliarden neutrinos auf jeden
quadratzentimeter der erde ein
sie stammen von gigantischen ereignissen
im weltall wie den supernova explosionen
oder gammastrahlen ausbrüchen und ihre
unfassbare beschleunigung kann man sich
gar nicht vorstellen
teilweise wurden tatsächlich neutrinos
mit einer energie von 980 tera
elektronenvolt analysiert zum vergleich
im l
dem large hadron collider im genfer
kernforschungszentrum cern sind protonen
mit energien von 13 tera elektronenvolt
am start und noch eine ziemlich krass
randnotiz mittlerweile wurden mit hilfe
des klubs ob sie es auch schon teilchen
im bereich von peter elektronenvolt
gemessen also mehr als 1000 tera
elektronenvolt trinos haben im gegensatz
zu anderen teilchen eine ganz besondere
eigenschaft sie interagieren kaum oder
nur sehr selten mit materie
daraus ergibt sich aber auch dass sie
nicht abgelenkt werden
sie fliegen direkt von der
strahlungsquelle geradeaus durchs all
und deshalb kann man nur bei ihnen
herausfinden woher sie kommen und damit
woher ihre unglaublichen energien
stammen allerdings dauert es immer eine
ziemliche zeit bis die daten analysiert
sind und deshalb stammt diese neuigkeit
in diesem video vom ersten oktober 2009
10 die lichtsensoren des ice cube
detektors am südpol hatten ein neutrino
detektiert das mit hoher energie
eingeflogen waren dazu anfang ehemalige
forscherin am deutschen
elektronen-synchrotron desy das zeichen
war in das antarktische eisschild einer
bemerkenswerten energie von mehr als 100
tera elektronenvolt gerauscht zum
vergleich das ist mindestens die
zehnfache teilchen energie die der
größte teilchenbeschleuniger der erde
erreichen kann
der large hadron collider am
europäischen kernforschungszentrum cern
bei genf
und bei diesem neutrino konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
besonders genau identifizieren woher das
neutrino stammte so kamen die fachleute
auf die spur eines gigantischen
kosmischen teilchen beschleuniger ist
ein glücksfall dass nun aufgespürte
neutrino dass 2019 detektiert wurde
konnte nach aufwändigen analysen einem
supermassereichen schwarzen loch in
einer fernen galaxie zugewiesen werden
die fachleute schätzen die masse des
gigantischen schwarzen lochs auf rund 30
millionen sonnenmassen sein zuhause eine
namenlose galaxie im sternbild delfin
der stern war diese massemonster zu nahe
gekommen und war dann durch seine enorme
schwerkraft zerstört worden so hat das
nun aufgespürte neutrino also eine reise
von rund 700 millionen jahren hinter
sich damals hatten sich gerade die
ersten tiere auf der erde entwickelt den
ablauf dieser sogenannten gezeigten
katastrophe beschreibt der
wissenschaftler robert stein vom
deutschen elektronen synchrotron desy
vor
unser maßen die schwerkraft wird stärker
und stärker je näher man einem objekt
kommt das bedeutet auch dass das
schwarze loch an der etwas nehren
vorderseite des sterns stärker bezogen
hat als an seiner etwas weiter
entfernten rückseite die differenz die
den stern gedehnt hat heißt gezeiten
kraft und je näher der stern dem
schwarzen loch kommt bis zu extremer
wird er in die länge gezogen irgendwann
reißt es den stern auseinander
dann haben wir einige zeiten katastrophe
es ist dem prinzip derselbe prozess der
auf der erde für ebbe und flut sorgt
aber zum glück für uns zieht der mond
nicht stark genug an der erde um sie
auseinanderzureißen
in der fachwelt ist von einem
sogenannten teile des hradschin event i
die rede
gemeint ist damit eine helligkeit
veränderung die entsteht wenn ein stern
einem supermassereichen schwarzen noch
zu nahe kommt und dann zerrissen wird
die gezeitenkräfte sorgen dafür dass das
objekt zunächst in die länge gezogen
wird und das gas teils weggeschleudert
wird die materie sammelt sich dann in
der akkretionsscheibe die um das
schwarze loch kreist nach und nach wird
sie von diesem verschlungen wobei sich
der stern rest erhitzt das abstrahlen
war dann bis zur erde sichtbar und genau
solch eine helligkeit veränderung hatten
astronomen astronomen bereits im april
vor zwei jahren 2009/10 bemerkt ein
hinweis auf anteile destruction event
also bereits ein halbes jahr vor dem
neutrino treffer am südpol an wirklich
spektakuläres ereignis also dass ich da
im sternbild delfin zugetragen hat und
so haben die fachleute mit zahlreichen
verschiedenen instrumenten dieses
ereignis genauer analysiert dazu robert
stein vom tcs ist das erste neutrino von
einer gezeigten katastrophe und es
liefert uns wertvolle hinweise gezeigten
katastrophen sind bislang wenig
verstanden der neutrino von weist auf
die existenz einer zentralen mächtigen
maschinerie nahe der akkretionsscheibe
die schnelle teilchen ausspuckt und die
kombinierte analyse der daten der radio
optischen und ultraviolett teleskope
belegt zusätzlich das gezeigten
katastrophen als gigantische
teilchenbeschleuniger funktionieren
können
fachleute aus den usa haben dazu ein
modell entwickelt über das sie ebenfalls
in einer aktuellen studie berichten
demnach spuckt der kosmische
beschleuniger verschiedene arten von
teilchen aus und die meisten von ihnen
sind elektrisch geladen
diese werden daher auf ihr
reise durch das all von
intergalaktischen magnetfeldern
abgelenkt die neutrinos aber sind
elektrisch neutral und reisen genauso
wie photonen also licht auf einer
geraden linie durch sein da sie sich
zurückverfolgen lassen sind sie für
forschungsteams besonders interessant
und in der zukunft erwarten die
fachleute noch viele weitere
erkenntnisse in diesem zusammenhang dazu
der us forscher francis helfen
wir sehen hier vielleicht erst die
spitze des eisbergs künftig erwarten wir
viele weitere solcher verbindung
zwischen energiereichen neutrinos und
ihren fällen es wird gerade eine neue
generation von teleskopen gebaut die
eine höhere empfindlichkeit für
gezeigten katastrophen und andere
vermutliche neutrino quellen bieten
noch wichtiger ist der geplante ausbau
des ice cube neutrino den text los wurde
durch sich die zahl der beobachteten
kosmischen neutrinos mindestens 14
fachen dürfte doch das ist nicht die
einzige entdeckung des ice cube
observatoriums in diesen tagen denn die
auswertung von daten aus dem archiv mit
hilfe eines lernfähigen algorithmus also
künstliche intelligenz offenbart einen
weiteren spektakulären fangen der
bereits vor fünf jahren im dezember 2016
erfolgte denn damals war wohl erstmals
ein kosmisches antineutrinos eingefangen
worden
dieses stammt aus einer fremden galaxie
und raste dann mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
durch das antarktische eis dabei
kollidierte es mit einem elektron und so
kam es zu der entstehung von mehreren
sekundären teilchen und photonen diese
wurden von den photo detektoren des
observatoriums angefangen doch erst
jetzt mit hilfe des lernfähigen
algorithmus wurde den fachleuten die
besondere bedeutung bewusst denn dieses
ereignis kann möglicherweise eine
theorie aus der physik beweisen die
bereits 60 jahre alt ist aber bislang
eben noch nie experimentell bewiesen
werden konnte
die rede ist von der vorhersage des
physikers sheldon lucio der sich auf ein
im jahr 1960 noch unentdeckten
elementarteilchen bezieht das sogenannte
w boson es handelt sich um einen
vermittler teilchen der schwachen
kernkraft das entsteht wenn schnelle und
energiereiche antineutrinos mit
elektronen interagieren 25 jahre später
also 1985 gelang dann tatsächlich der
nachweis doch der damals entdeckte
entstehungsmechanismus des w boson zwar
ein anderer die sogenannte gläschen
resonanz also der weg wie sich
schildesche ein solches w boson bildet
blieb um bewiesen denn das ist auf der
erde quasi unmöglich da eine enorme
energie von 6,3 peter elektronenvolt das
sind 6300 tera elektronenvolt
aufgewiesen werden muss zum vergleich
der large hadron collider lhc der
stärkste teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
schafft es nur auf etwa 1 5 hundertstel
davon kein experiment auf dieser erde
schafft es also diese theorie zu
beweisen
doch kam es jetzt etwa bei der kollision
des antineutrinos mit einem elektronen
im südpol eis zur gläschen resonanz
tatsächlich offenbaren die analysen dass
das ereignis vom 6 dezember mehr als 6
peter elektronenvolt freisetzte die form
und zeitliche verteidigung der licht und
teilchen spur weist zudem darauf hin
dass es sich nicht um ein neutrino
sondern um ein anti neutrino gehandelt
haben muss also der antimaterie
gegenpart des neutrinos und alleine das
ist für die fachwelt eine sensation denn
bislang weiß man zu den antineutrinos
kaum etwas wo und wie entstehen diese
etwa in schwarzen löchern oder quasi
dazu der wissenschaftler
frühere messungen konnten den
unterschied zwischen neutrinos und
antineutrinos nicht auflösen
dieses ergebnis ist die erste direkte
messung eines antineutrinos aus dem
astrophysikalischen neutrino einstrom
zudem gibt es tatsächlich auch ein
hinweis auf die gletscher resonanz das
muster der photonen die bei der passage
des antineutrinos erzeugt wurden hat das
anti neutrino also eine größere resonanz
verursacht dem forschungsteam zufolge
könnte bei der kollision mit einem
elektron zunächst ein velo sohn
entstanden sein das dann in sekundäre
teilchen zerfallen ist wenn das
tatsächlich so sein sollte würde sich um
den ersten experimentellen nachweis
einer resonanz handeln dazu us-forscher
fans helfen als kleschtschow damals am
niels bohr institut seine theorie
aufstellte hätte er sich sicher nicht
träumen lassen dass sein
unkonventioneller weg zur wm produktion
einmal von einem anti neutrino aus einer
fernen galaxie umgesetzt werden würde
doch zunächst steht noch ein weiterer
nachweis an der gelingen muss um die
glescher resonanz zweifelsfrei zu
beweisen
doch hier sind die fachleute
optimistisch auch in den blick auf die
erweiterung des ice cube detektors unter
anderem sollen
150 weitere photodetektoren im südpol
eis eingelassen werden auch der detektor
so langfristig ausgeweitet werden auf
das zehnfache seines heutigen volumen es
bleibt also spannend im ice cube in der
antarktis aber auch im weltraum exklusiv
hier auf klicks und könnt ihr
zusammentreffen mit esa generaldirektor
josef aschbacher der astronautin
kandidatin in satire dem
europaabgeordneten niklas ninas von den
grünen und mir unser thema das space
race 2.0 das neue wettrennen in den
weltraum und wie europa nicht den
anschluss verliert anmelden könnt ihr
euch hier also anklicken und dann dabei
sein und das ganze gibt es dann live 4
auf klicks um am 18 märz um 19 uhr
ich freue mich auf euch und eine rege
teilnahme der link ist natürlich auch in
der video beschreibung und im
angepeilten kommentar bis dann bleibt
dran